so ponzi scheme you know the word ponzi
came about this was this guy there was a
guy named ponzi okay so
what's the whole thing about a ponzi
scheme and a pyramid scheme you hear
these words ponzi scheme pyramid
everything nowadays called the pyramid
scheme everything nowadays is called a
ponzi scheme it's very easy people drop
that word regularly right nft is being
called that you know
cryptocurrency has been called that a
lot of things i've called the
a multi-level marketing has been called
pyramid scheme or ponzi scheme but the
challenge where some people win
is when there's not an actual usage of
the product
let me let me say that one more time
there's not an actual usage
of the product meaning the product they
sell is not being used
if i'm anybody right now i want to get
to the 60
number 70 number which means something
there's got to be 70 of the people that
buy this coin
use the technology use other aspects of
it rather than just
a uh
yeah so for example hypothetically
more
all these guys that are pro bitcoin pro
ethereum pro you know whatever doge you
know you just saw elon musk yesterday
they said we're not going to be taking
payment for what through doge right
because he says uh the technology is
better than xy even though this started
as a meme thing it's better than uh all
the other guys are technology yeah
elon musk is doing the right thing
what elon musk is doing is he's making
it he's giving it credibility so for
example
insurance companies need to start
accepting bitcoin as a payment like when
you talked about the whole i trust
capital which is the ira that's great
small businesses need to start more
taking bitcoin as a payment ethereum as
a payment more of these folks that are
pro crypto the future which is that's
the direction you're going decentralized
the bank can no longer bully you and do
all the other stuff powell can no longer
control your life any of those things
great
but there needs to be a major push into
the usage of the technology rather than
the investment
if they win there i think uh you you're
a hundred percent on and that's why i
brought up the utility
listen i can make a very good argument
that xrp
is being utilized way more than bitcoin
or ethereum as it relates to just that
token being usage cross-border payments
uh people get on the ledger they send
money you
there's a an app a developer independent
of ripple called spin the bits and it's
spending bitcoin where he uses the xrp
ledger as a layer two solution to the
bitcoin network problem right it takes
10 minutes at the low end for bitcoin to
an hour for the transaction to go on the
ledger instantaneously ripples xrp is
instantaneous three to five seconds and
you know when you had kurt on here and
he said you know bitcoin uh is um is
like seven transactions btc on and uh
ether is 15.
ripple xrp
the token 1300 per second transactions
and fraction of a penny i can move i've
watched it i can move two million
dollars worth of bitcoin
for a fraction of a penny using the xrp
ledger as you said earlier the
technology is awesome
it's absolutely in my opinion the
superior tech as far as the network
and i think when you get to usage xrp is
ahead of the game uh that's that's where
you win you win you win there that's my
opinion i may be wrong but i think you
win
by me needing to use the product if i
use the product it validates that it's
not just an investment here's the
problem though guys right and this is
the beauty of decentralization and this
is also you know this is where
decentralization lags behind
who's the patrick bet david of of ripple
who's moving the company forward from a
marketing perspective who's out there
creating the infrastructure necessary
who's got the user interface so that
everybody can get on their phone and
within you know three seconds learn how
to use the product and use all these
different ledgers that we're talking
about who's going to teach my mother how
to use ripple on a day-to-day it was
impossible to teach her how to use venmo
it took like two years to get her to get
her on venmo you know what i'm saying so
that that's that becomes the issue with
with cryptos going forward
who which community can come together
and coagulate in in a common direction
that there's going they're going to have
the bitcoin atms and somebody's going to
have the conversations with you know
mutual of omaha and say you should be
using you know bitcoin to take payments
like who's who's out there actively
selling who's out there actively
marketing who's out there actively
creating infrastructure and these usage
things there's a trillion dollar
industry trillion dollar industry in the
future for people that i mean think
about it think about the very first
person who allows
ezpass to have bitcoin and takes
you know one tenth of a cent of a
transaction for every easy pass that
goes through every toll in the country
right that they're they're they're
they're worth a trillion dollars no
you're right so i mean like but who
who's doing that i mean right now like
what who is who is pushing that
technology forward who's the driving
force behind that technology in these in
these because these aren't like
companies they're like
organizations they're they're they're
you know it's the beauty of it it's the
wild wild west right there's no
directive well two things you'd be a
great securities lawyer because do you
know consumptive use defeats the whole
case
for ri for xrp or ether gets sued the
sec in the complaint they have an entire
section that tries to say there is no
consumptive use it is all mere
speculation there are no users of the
network so you're 100 on point and the
problem the danger why this case is so
dangerous is what you just said who's
out there
promoting it because once you are a
promoter
are you a common enterprise
are you leading people to a reasonable
expectation of profit based on your
efforts you know if if somebody was a
drug dealer that started it is it now a
rico case are you now complicit in
international smuggling like if you buy
like
this this stuff's the wild west man nfts
like i saw and and you as a lawyer i'm
sure you've heard this as well
there are people out there right now
right that are creating an nft for 300
ethereum okay they've got a million
dollars in ethereum sitting in the bank
they buy their own nft for a million
dollars ethereum they spent a million
dollars but now they have the nft and
the million dollars ethereum right they
sell it at a loss
for half a million dollars so they lost
on the ledger a half million dollars
they took a half million dollar loss but
they got a million and a half ethereum
right you can do that over and over and
over it's not illegal right now right
you get you're getting a half million
dollar loss and you're increasing your
wealth
i i is that what what's going on with
the nfts i mean is that the idea think
about think about it from this
standpoint okay what allows the
government to want to tighten up
regulation on guns what what allows it
like think about what helps their
argument public perception no forget
public perception it's dummies
who
do stupid things that are irresponsible
with a gun then the politician comes out
and says what i told you i'll say it we
we have to you know and you know what my
governor newsom i'm gonna do exactly
what texas did to abortion we're gonna
do to guns in california here's what
we're going to do moving forward you can
no longer buy
right so
meaning where i'm going with this is the
final one
the the quick money get rich quick
scheme type of guys are unfortunately
unfortunately
making life
difficult for the rest of the guys that
are doing it the right way the long-term
play-wise and this has been going on for
a while
government the the regulators they they
they love
that that one percent of the con men
that are you know that are trying to
they say you see
you see that's exactly why we need to
protect you might be there i'm that
person it might be them they're the ones
going around breaking
gary ginsler just did that
just a couple weeks ago when he brought
up bitcoin someone brought a bitcoin he
goes it's being used for ransomware do
you know what percentage
that that really is being used to play
but that's the best that's the play and
you know like for example i uh
last year we had a couple hundred
thousand dollars of fake valuetainment
consulting bitcoin stolen and we get the
calls and i get on the phone with these
guys like listen that's not us right
that's not us look at the email you got
that's from
davidcryptospecialty
at gmail.com i said that's not us buddy
we don't have that website that's not
our website let's go look at the ip
address oh i feel so bad my wife is
so upset at me so so there is that going
on as well absolutely so there's got to
be a part on
you know
a a society has to either accept the
fact that if that happens to you you
were the one that didn't verify the
source that was coming your way so you
deserve exactly what you got right or
a society needs to say no we need to
figure out a way to eliminate 100 of
that and that's when these government
people come in and they feel special
that they're needed to do their job and
then they go
turn one small regulation into 78
different regulations and then another
guy comes in try deregulating stuff so
my concern is
they're going to point to these guys and
say this is why you need our help what
would you what would you which would you
prefer in that spectrum you know which
one i would prefer uh to me i would
prefer uh look the whole concept of
valuetainment is what education that's
the whole concept of acetaminophen look
here's what to look out for here's what
to be paranoid about when you're raising
money keep these things in mind before
you raise money ask these 10 questions
before you're hiring somebody ask them
these five questions before you open up
an office and sign a lease
know what the commercial real estate guy
makes here's what their motive is
understand yeah so so to me i'm all
about educate educate educate educate
educate and then look if you screw up
it's on you i've screwed up god knows
how much money i've lost grown up that's
organic regulation and that's organic
regulation a part of that that's got to
be organic regulation
but there are those
who abuse others
my punishment for abuse would go higher
my punishment to to want to hurt
somebody's livelihood and their savings
if you do that
i uh it wouldn't sit very well with less
laws but harsher consequences less laws
harsher consequences my approach is what
it would be the problem we have though
is it's always an extreme it's either
no regulation or it's a nanny state
you know and that's the problem it's
the financial crisis after it came down
and dodd-frank was passed and all that
i couldn't get a mortgage to my home and
i just wanted a home equity loan even
though i had the home was worth
two-thirds what i'm asking for and i had
five times that in a savings account but
they said because one year
i fell under a certain threshold at my
law firm you know settlements were
delayed or
whatnot doing they're doing the exact
same thing now with covet they're doing
the exact same thing now they're telling
people that they had a lapse of income
they were like yeah right
the world was shut down right but but
before that anyone it was no
verification income loans it was no uh
no jobs occasionally all those things
that's the predatory lending so but the
problem we have right now is when a
situation like this case happens and
certain government officials start
picking the winners and losers and
that's what's happened in this
particular case so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you